were you affected by the wildfires
they've been you know had were a lot of
fires yes a lot of fires here lately
there was just one the other day over
the weekend right outside our studios
thankfully the amazing I thought over
there firefighters took care of it they
did an amazing job but you were were you
displaced it all do deals did not burn
down no you know I did not yes we had to
evacuate actually for for two nights and
it's interesting when you have to
evacuate your house at the last minute
it's very telling about what you take
with you and what you cherish in life
I you know I have some guitars I grabbed
my best guitar mm-hmm I grabbed my
laptop and I grabbed a photo album
mm-hmm and I said honey I'll be back in
a couple of
[Laughter]
audience this audience applause a
tragedy
yeah no it's not true I know my wife and
my son would be the first things I would
take yeah they're fantastic yeah good
good good cover on that we've known each
other a very long time I work to keep a
concern at live and I'm always known
you're not going yes okay all right so I
remember that you and I've always
thought of you as a guy very nice very
funny but I feel like you're holding in
stress like you have a lot of stress and
you hold it in is that a fair thing to
say seriously if you were a therapist
I'd say would be fair yeah I do I you
know I I'm the kind of guy I'd hate
confrontations so I hope I have so much
I want to say to you but I'm not gonna I
hold I hold in a lot of things and it's
stress and it creates stress I think you
know at night I grind my teeth Oh like
you do them yeah so they got they got me
on night guard which is basically a guy
with a uniform that stands kidding I'm
kidding
okay can we be serious for a minute
there's a guard that stands there on
guards you okay and when I ground my
teeth he puts his finger in erotic turns
like I never thought of as a rock so I
think sorry
it's a medical it's my fantasy I don't
stick my tongue out first of all he just
just interested in okay no it's a it's a
mouthpiece that fits in there when you
grind you know and then my teeth started
separating on the bottom over the years
and somebody dentist got me a retainer
to put in No
and and then come to find out that I
have sleep apnea I store a lot so I have
to wear a CPAP machine now at night
which is a full face mask with a hose
that runs yes now my wife is like Jesus
this is like sleeping with somebody in
ICU every night and then I started
getting all jealous I said how do you
know that have you slept with somebody
are you singing